Speaker 1: We start today with a major story, the
wife of Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas,
Ginni Thomas, we now know, was way more involved
in the lead up to and supporting the attempts
to overthrow the correct, accurate, real
winner of the 2020 presidential election.
She was involved in emails with Donald Trump's
attorneys. She was involved in emails with Arizona
lawmakers who were trying to figure out a way.
Remember this alternate slate of electors that
they wanted to send to Washington, D.C.? Ginni
Thomas was extremely involved, and we now know
it now. We suspected this for months because of
little bits of data and evidence here and there.
But now, thanks to the January 6th committee,
the degree to which Ginni Thomas was involved
and we must wonder. What about Clarence
Thomas? I mean, is it is it really plausible
that he has no idea what she's up to and not at
all supportive of what she's up to? It starts to
become hard to believe. So let's go to the primary
report about this from The Washington Post.
Ginni Thomas corresponded with John Eastman.
Sources in the January 6th House investigation
say the House committee investigating the January
six attacks has obtained email correspondence
between Jenny Thomas, the wife of Clarence Thomas,
and lawyer John Eastman, who played a key role
in efforts to pressure Vice President Pence to
block the certification of Joe Biden's victory.
This is according to three people involved in
the investigation. Remember Eastman's the guy
who wrote the memo telling Mike Pence or rather
wrote the memo explaining how Mike Pence could
reject the election results and send it back to
the states, as they love to say. None of this is
true. None of this is real. None of this is based
on reality in reality. But that's who John Eastman
is. And Ginni Thomas was corresponding directly
with him. The article goes on to say The emails
show that Thomas is effort to overturn the
election were more extensive than previously
known. The three declined to provide details and
spoke on the condition of anonymity. The committee
staffers and members are now discussing whether
to spend time during the public hearings exploring
Jenny Thomas's role in trying to overturn the
outcome of the 2020 election, the Washington Post
previously reported. The committee had not sought
an interview with Thomas and was leaning against
pursuing her cooperation. The two people said the
emails were among documents obtained and reviewed
recently. Last week, a federal judge ordered
Eastman to turn more than 100 documents over
to the committee. Eastman was trying to block
those. Thomas also sent messages to President
Trump's White House chief of staff, Mark Meadows,
that this is Ginni Thomas was in touch with
Eastman, Mark Meadows and two Arizona lawmakers
pressing them to help overturn the election.
Thomas has maintained she and her husband
operate in separate professional lanes. Her
activities as a conservative political activist
have long distinguished her from other spouses
of Supreme Court justices. Any new revelations
about her actions after the 2020 election are
likely to further intensify questions about
whether Thomas, Clarence Thomas, should recuse
himself from cases related to the election
and attempt to subvert it. This is a major,
major deal. One other piece of this that I
wanted to mention to you. About the Arizona
element. Um, she was in touch with 27. Here we go.
In the weeks after the 2020 election, Ginni Thomas
repeatedly pressed Mark Meadows to overturn the
outcome. As if he can do it, she told Meadows in
a text she was disgusted with Pence, who didn't
block the certification of Biden's victory.
She said, We are living through what feels like
the end of America. And then during the same
period, she was pressing Republican lawmakers in
Arizona to help keep Trump in office by setting
aside Biden's popular vote win and choosing their
own electors, which is completely and absolutely
bonkers. So this is truly madness. Now, there
are reports that Liz Cheney, who's on the January
six committee, has been hesitant or resisting,
really pulling in Jenny Thomas into part of the
investigation. But these are absolutely questions
that Americans deserve to see answered publicly,
particularly particularly if elements of the
January six riots may come before the Supreme
Court. I'm not sure about this. It would be a
waste of time to bring Jenny Thomas in. Well,
I don't know about that, but the involvement of
Jenny Thomas needs to be looked at completely.
And it is it it's damning that Clarence Thomas
did not recuse himself on the January six document
production case that made its way to the Supreme
Court. Think about it. On the one hand, his wife
is out there involved in trying to make certain
things happen on January 6th and also is mentioned
in all sorts of the documents that are at issue
that so his wife is related. She is a party to
many of these documents and communications, and
he then gets to decide whether it's appropriate
or not, whether it's legally justified or not
for documents to be released and turned over.
That's outrageous. It's completely outrageous.
And just think for a second. Imagine that it was
Sonia Sotomayor's husband who was in a similar
situation, who had been texting and emailing
and pushing for the election to be given to
someone other than the person who actually won.
Do you think Republicans would be silent? No,
it would be 24 seven on Fox News. The Hunter
Biden laptop story, which is almost nothing. Look
at how much coverage that received. Imagine if
you know a family member of Elena Kagan was there.
It's outrageous. And this has to be explored. And
there are so many extremists. Listen, they're
not just close to the government. They're in
government as well. But even on the periphery of
government and then on the periphery of power,
they are everywhere. And it is very difficult
to believe here. We're making a judgment call.
I don't know that much about Jenny and Clarence
Thomas relationship, but do we really believe that
Ginni Thomas is this involved? She's contacting
lawmakers. She's in touch with the president's
chief of staff. She's in touch with John Eastman.
And Clarence Thomas knows nothing, has no opinion
and is completely neutral about what she's
doing. Right. Like, imagine that. Hey, Clarence,
I'm in touch with Eastman. I'm in touch with
Meadows. I'm trying to keep Trump in power. I'm
trying to push for a different slate of electors
to be sent from Arizona. And Clarence Thomas goes.
Oh, that's really interesting. I have no opinion
one way or the other about what you're doing.
Give me a break, guys. And I know there are
some weird relationships in Washington, D.C.,
but it is very difficult to imagine that that's
the case now at this point. What I would I mean,
you know, we talk about taking the high road.
Taking the low road. Democrats should do
what Republicans would do if the situation was
reversed. Go to them and go to Thomas and say,
listen, Clarence Thomas needs to go. Clarence
Thomas should resign. We'll have Joe Biden pick
a right leaning justice so it won't change the
balance of the court and then rammed through a
progressive in the middle of the night. This
is what this is what Republicans would do.
Okay. And this is what Democrats should
do. If you disagree with me, let me know.